-Welcome back to "The Tonight Show."
It is time to play a game called "Auto-Tune Up."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Auto-tuned] ♪ Oh ♪
♪ Auto ♪
♪ Tune up, yeah ♪
♪ Ohhh, no, no, no ♪
[ Laughter ] -Wow.
I'm going to need a little help right now.
He's one of the hosts of the new NBC competition show
"Dancing with Myself."
Here is Nick Jonas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about. That's what I'm talking about.
That's exactly right.
That's --
That's what I'm talking about right there.
Nick Jonas, the one and only. That's what I'm talking about.
-Thank you. -Welcome, buddy.
Now, here's how it works.
We're going to take turns hitting this button right here,
and it will select a random, boring
Internet post or something.
Our job is to turn it
into an awesome song with the help of auto-tune.
Are you ready for this? -I am ready.
-Alright. Let's do this. I'm up first.
Let's see what I'm auto-tuning. Start the generator, please.
[ Beeping ]
[ Whoosh ]
A post on a Dr. Pepper message board.
Alright, so, I'm gonna auto-tune a post
on a Dr. Pepper message board.
Roots, whenever you're ready.
-Alright. Here we go.
♪♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Hmm ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, hmm ♪
♪ Hmm-hah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
-How did they get my post from the Dr. Pepper forum?
-Almost 2:00 in the morning on a post on a Dr. Pepper forum.
Alright, here we go. Nick, it is your turn.
Let's see. Let's start the generator and see what you get.
Press the button when you're ready.
[ Whoosh ]
-Oh.
-A Craigslist ad for a roommate. -Alright.
-You're going to auto-tune a Craigslist ad for a roommate.
Nick Jonas, whenever you're ready, bud.
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I said 2,400 a month ♪
♪ Hmm ♪
-[ Laughing ] -Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ "Heyyy" ♪
[ Laughs ] -Yeah.
-That's how you do it right there. Oh, my gosh.
Alright. It's my turn.
Let's see what I'm going to sing here.
[ Beeping ]
[ Whoosh ]
A post on Facebook Marketplace.
Facebook Marketplace.
That's like an Etsy type of thing?
Or like a garage sale -- Just selling --
-I don't know what Facebook is.
-Yeah I don't know -- But Marketplace --
Okay. Thank you. Alright. Here we go.
A post on Facebook Marketplace.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hm, closing down ♪
♪ Hmm ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Even with auto-tune, it sounded bad.
Okay. Last song. Let's start the generator.
Here we go. [ Beeping ]
Whenever you're ready.
Instructions on how to boil a hot dog in the microwave.
-Alright. -This should be good. Okay.
-This should be good.
-Instructions on how to boil a hot dog in a microwave.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you do it, buddy. That was amazing.
Give it up! Nick Jonas right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're talking to Nick after the break.
Stick around, everybody.